tous les sportifs un petit peu du
dimanche se reconnaissent en moi et j'ai
besoin de voir mes amis j'ai besoin de
sortir j'aime voir mon petit verre
d'alcool je vois là ça me fait du bien
j'aime faire un petit barbecue l'après
midi est posée au bord de la piscine
rien faire ne pas faire de sport peut
faire du tennis après ce qu'il faut
c'est arrivé à trouver le juste milieu à
faire aussi la fête mais aussi être
sérieux et à bien préparer les tournois
donc c'est ce que j'ai un peu plus de
mal à faire en ce moment c'est pour ça
que là je vais je vais repartir à zéro
ça fait deux jours que j'ai pas bu
d'alcool donc voilà je suis en pleine
cure
c'est vrai que je prends du plaisir
quand je vais m'entraîner quand je joue
avec mes amis mais arriver sur un match
de tennis en ce moment alors je sais pas
si c'est le fait que je me sente pas
forcément très bien physiquement ou quoi
que ce soit mais j'ai un peu d'angoissé
un peu de stress à arriver sur un court
alors que c'est ce qui faisait que
j'étais bon en avant c'est que même sans
beaucoup m'entraîner j'arrivais à sortir
des gros match parce que justement j'ai
aimé ça l'adrénaline j'ai aimé les
moments de stress et maintenant c'est
devenu de plus en plus compliquées dès
que je suis stressée je je m'angoisse et
je panique c'est difficile parce que je
me sens pas forcément heureux aussi dans
ma vie parce que le tennis est compliqué
donc c'est un cercle vicieux dernière
fois
plus
en fait j'en ai pris cette année une
fois à l'open d'australie ce avec
voilà je sentais que je sortais d'une
période de quarantaine j'avais fait
qu'un jour encore enfermé dans ma
chambre je suis arrivé à l'open
d'australie sans entraînement sans
préparation et j'étais tellement motivé
de vouloir montrer que je jouais
toujours béante et nice que j'étais
capable de faire de belles choses si
dans ça faisait voilà je pense que
depuis le coc vide il n'a pas eu
beaucoup de moments je me sentis très
heureux mais c'est trop
j'ai surtout appris à faire des
cocktails après les squats en pleine
séance de gainage non je rigole
[Musique]
santé
le plus dur c'est d'arriver de faire son
test de se sentir positif au moins
savait que ça c'était le plus dur j'ai
été trois fois positif au vide une fois
qu'à contacter j'ai fait trois isolement
de 14 jours dans une chambre d'hôtel ça
a pas aidé non plus à ce que j'avais
bien mentalement
ouh là ça commence à devenir dur pas le
droit de sortir de ma charge et des
fenêtres qui sont condamnés donc c'est
pas facile mais un voilà a été des
moments très compliqués à vivre
prévost là les gens se rendent pas
forcément compte ils vont se dire ah il
se plaint alors qu'il vient des beaux
hôtels dans les bons endroits mais quand
on est isolé comme ça à l'autre bout du
monde qu'on peut pas sortir qu'on fait
que deux ibériques et qu'on a un
policier qui est devant la chambre parce
qu'on n'a pas droit de sortir ça vexe et
c'est pas des sensations qu'on a envie
de vivre et c'est pour ça que je me
sentais peut-être mieux chez moi il faut
du temps encore pour se remettre de
cette situation je pense que c'est pour
tous les méchants pas et c'est pas que
pour les sportifs je pense que pour
toutes les personnes qui ont connu
confinement qu'ont connu ça et
franchement il faut du temps pour s'en
remettre je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
sportifs qui l'ont mal vécu
moi encore plus parce que je suis assez
sensible à ces motifs donc forcément
tout ce qui s'est passé m'a touché ma
fait peut-être plus de mal que d'autres
nous on nous voit comme des joueurs de
tennis professionnels et andy bailly les
professionnels donc il doit être comme
ci comme ça mais au final on est comme
tout le monde on a nos problèmes on a
nos défauts et savez quand ça va pas
bien a réduit comme tout le monde quand
ils sont au travail peuvent pas donner
100% de dans n'importe quel travail et
c'est vrai que c'est la même chose pour
un jour le tennis c'est bien de parler
aussi que nous on est des sportifs on
est avant tout des êtres humains et
c'est important de remettre les choses à
leur place et dire que nous aussi on
peut avoir des failles ce qui est dur
c'est quand on est dans des périodes
comme la mienne en ce moment où c'est
plus difficile sur le plan tennistique
mentalement c'est un peu plus délicat là
qu'on reçoit des messages en plus déjà
que nous on n'est pas bien je trouve que
c'est la période où c'est la plus dure
pour recevoir des messages de lighters
et de parieurs qui ont perdu un pari où
ils ont perdu 2 euros mais j'ai jamais
vu une quiche pareil c'est la plus
grosse merde française que je connais tu
quelqu'un qui à venir sur justement les
réseaux sociaux qui a uni enfin peu tous
les messages qu'on m'envoie
quand ça se passe bien c'est vrai qu'on
est content parce qu'on a beaucoup de
messages positifs mais il faut savoir
que quand même quand on gagne on reçoit
beaucoup de messages négatifs parce
qu'au final on a gagné donc elle a
comparé sur l'adversaire et ils vont
quand même temps moyen message donc
est-ce qu'on s'y habitue je dirais que
non là moi je leur ai pas dit de paris
sur moi par exemple c'est eux qui font
leur choix je peux comprendre qu'ils
soient déçus mais qu'ils soient déçus
envers eux mêmes par vernon nous on n'y
est pour rien qu'on s'est vraiment
éclaté au sol tu es un français qui fait
honte salut c'est très agressif alors
quand cette limite trop agressif au
moins on lit le début et puis enfermé à
presse avec à des messages plus
difficile où c'est quand même des
menaces de mort c'est pas si simple à
gérer tous les jours mais on s'y habitue
pas mais on est obligé de faire avec
ouais ouais largement je pense que j'ai
déjà été blessé pendant six mois avec
des problèmes de genoux mais pour moi
c'est incomparable parce qu'en fait je
savais exactement quand ça allait aller
mieux quand ça allait se guérir là je
suis dans une situation finalement ma
tête je ne sais pas quand elle valait
mieux donc ça fait déjà deux ans chalco
vite ça fait
depuis début de l'année où j'ai vraiment
du mal mentalement donc pour moi je vais
ce qui est dur c'est de ne pas savoir
quand ça va se guérir et est du coup
c'est une blessure qui peut être très
long j'espère qu'elle sera le plus gros
possible mais c'est vrai que ça peut
être long ça peut prendre du temps là je
trouve que ça va un petit peu mieux je
dis pas que je vais très bien mais je
dis que ça va un petit peu mieux que
j'ai pris conscience qu'il me fallait de
l'aide j'ai pris conscience qu'il
fallait que je sois mais sur le terrain
qu'il fallait qu'ils soient plus
préparés physiquement je vois des psy je
vois pas mal de revers samedi justement
pour essayer de comprendre ce qui
m'arrive consulter
je l'avais jamais fait en fait parce que
j'étais toujours dit que j'y arriverai
tout seul que j'avais pas besoin d'être
que j'avais que ça servait à rien et
finalement je me suis rendu compte que
tout seul je m'en sortais pas donc ouais
je consulte un hypnotiseur je consulte
un psy colonnes voilà j'ai un
préparateur mental pour essayer de
discuter de pas mal de choses pas mal de
sujets et c'est justement de faire
sortir ce qui va pas très bien en ce
moment chez moi et c'est justement de
corriger ça c'est pas du tout pour
l'instant non mais oui je pense que
voilà c'est le début c'est à mon avis ça
se fait pas en une semaine donc il me
faut plusieurs sites
toujours pareil jamais chat complètement
nul si ça arrive parfois
en ce moment pas du tout je suis je suis
malchanceux j'ai pas de chat du tout
mais ça m'est arrivé une ou deux fois
dans ma vie peut-être mais la plupart du
temps c'est contre moi mais ce mot
c'était le mot le plus détesté de mon
père
dès que je disais ça quand j'étais plus
jeune parce que je le disais depuis que
je suis tout petit quand je le disais
mon père m'a engueulé mais il déteste et
ce mot et encore maintenant quand ils
voient maintenant mes t-shirts avec marc
et ça ça lui fait qu'elle est mal au
coeur
je crois pas je prends pas cela il veut
pas osé je pense que si je m'étais
entraîné beaucoup plus sérieusement que
si j'avais fait beaucoup plus d'efforts
je pense que j'aurais arrêté le tennis
très jeune pour moi j'ai besoin d'aimer
ce sport et c'est vrai que si j'en fais
trop au bout d'un moment je sature et je
sais que si je n'avais fait plus bas je
pense qu'aujourd'hui je serai pas là et
j'aurais déjà arrêté ma carrière depuis
longtemps donc chez l'un pas si j'aurais
pu être professionnel si j'avais joué
les tournois juniors si j'avais joué
tout ça je serais pas si
si je serais arrivé donc dire que j'ai
exploité peut-être 60% 70% pour moi
j'exploite à 100% ce que je peux faire
pour certaines personnes ils vont dire
non il aurait dû être plus sérieux plus
ils plus là mais pour moi je pense que
je fais 100 % alors peut-être pas à 100%
mais 95% de ce que je peux donner et si
non en fait ce qui est assez que
mentalement je sais pas si j'aurais pu
sur
lui revient maintenant mais c'est vrai
qu'il a eu des périodes très difficiles
mais mille lavaud il a été alcoolique
pendant un moment et il sortait tout le
temps il a joué un deuxième tour à
wimbledon ils étaient sortis jusqu'à 4
heures du matin son agent j'ai vu qu'ils
étaient venus chercher en boîte de nuit
voilà c'est vrai que c'est on est comme
ça on est quand même hyper sensible et
il est moindre quand ça va pas en fait
ça s'amplifie chez nous donc moi c'est
la période que je vis en ce moment lui
il a su s'en sortir j'ai vu qu'il était
qu'il était très bien en ce moment qu'il
était bien entouré voilà moi c'est ce
que je veux c'est qu'à un moment donné
je me sens bien dans ma vie pour être
bien dans ce bien sur le court
on vient pas me chercher c'est moitié
c'est moi qui rentre tout seul plus tôt
à 6 heures après